[Applause]
[Music]
you are the apex champions so you want
to become an apex legend or more
specifically an apex champion well
you've come to the right place my friend
we've rounded up nine tips at this
battle royale game doesn't quite tell
you so strap in now let's dive baby
number one you can go into your
inventory and request ammo and
attachments for a specific weapon
I need optics for an SMG pay attention
to squad chatter looks like a care
package is coming in big things in that
it's not just there for flavor but
actually contains useful info such as
informing you that your squad is
drifting apart or how far away you are
from the circle tons of stuff there 45
seconds
ring a Faro and this especially goes for
rape
having Wraith on your team will inform
your squad when another team sees you
lay traps or whether there are enemies
behind a closed door
tons of a little snippets there so pay
attention speaking of closed doors
kicked doors down to not just make an
entrance
but stun an enemy you can also get real
creative and blow them up sending the
door flying back and knocking back
another enemy
you know these spicy boy loot crate's
well guess what they're also in the game
and if you destroy them you get some
high tiered loot so just keep your eyes
and ears out for these little babies
some guns have different firing modes
tap left on the d-pad or B on PC and
swap from a full auto to a single shot
with certain high-level attachments the
triple shot sniper and peacemaker
shotgun can be charged up for more
powerful shots yellow tier legendary
loot have perks check your inventory to
find out legendary body armor for
instance will recharge your armor when
you execute people with a finisher if
you've noticed that the crater sniper
and Mastiff shotgun are in the menu but
wondering where they are in the game
there are in care packages those care
packages can be spotted from the blue
beams of light found randomly on the map
and lastly ultimate accelerators are
useful if you have lifeline spam those
as fast as you can to bring down the
loot and there you have it some starter
tips for apex legends if you got some
pointers yourself do add them in the
conversation below and as always thanks
for watching
yeah boy
good job